on est une des catégories
professionnelles qui malheureusement le
plus de touchés a fait par cette
pandémie
la procédure est devenu incontournable
les médecins qui travaillent en jaune
qu'ovide ressemble désormais à de vrais
astronautes en italie comme ailleurs
mais ce n'était pas le cas au début de
la pandémie
loin de là beaucoup de médecins était
inconscient il n'avait pas les bonnes
informations pour aller combattre voilà
ce virus beaucoup de médecins
généralistes ont dû aller à domicile ont
reçu beaucoup de patients avec des
symptômes qui ressemblaient à des de
monier ce sont en particulier les
médecins de campagne qui soigne à
domicile qui ont été infectés ils ont
également contribué à propager la
maladie en envoyant des centaines de
patients infectés dans des hôpitaux
régionaux mal préparée on peut parler de
surexposition c'est à dire avoir est en
contact avec une charge virale qui est
plus élevé que d'autres catégories de
personnes
la surexposition au virus a bel et bien
provoquer plus d'infections
comble de malchance plusieurs médecins
italiens à la retraite donc plus âgé est
potentiellement plus vulnérables avaient
été appelés en renfort
ce qui a entraîné plus de 17
les effectifs médicaux semble suffisant
pour l'instant mais le risque de
nouvelle éclosion est toujours présent
en italie avec le début progressif du
déconfinement donc on est un peu tous
dans les milieux hospitaliers un peu sur
le qui-vive en attendant de voir si nous
allons avoir des accès plus important de
positif qui arrive de sutter dans les
hôpitaux on n'est pas un prêt à tout
faire repartir en plein régime
si les médecins des centres hospitaliers
sont bien préparés les omnipraticiens
des régions et des grandes villes
italiennes se plaignent encore
aujourd'hui du nombre est suffisant
d'équipements de protection
sylvain desjardins radio canada montréal